مسيره الاعلام مظاهره اسرائيليه متطرفه كل
عام تهدف الى طمس الهويه العربيه
الفلسطينيه في القرص الشريف وجعلها عاصمه
موحده لاسرائيل منذ احتلالها عام 67
سلطات الاحتلال فرضت منذ الصباح طوقا
امنيا حول البلده القديمه وفي محيطها وعلى
ابوابها بل وحتى ازقتها وباحات المسجد
الاقصى
بدايه فرغت الباحات من الفلسطينيين
وذلك تمهيدا لاقتهامها من قبل مستوطنين
ومتطرفين يهود من بينهم اعضاء حاليون
وسابقون في الحكومه والكنيست
الاقتحمات سبقت مسيره ما يعرف برقصه
الاعلام الاف اليهود غالبهم من المستوطنين
يرفعون الاعلام الاسرائيليه في مسيره
تتكرر كل عام تدخل من باب العمود وتجوب في
ازقه البلده القديمه مرورا بالحي الاسلامي
ووصولا الى حائط البراق وزير الامن في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اتمار بن غفير شارك
ايضا في رقصه الاعلام الهدف هو خلق مدينه
القدس بكل قطاعاتها خلق الوجود الفلسطيني
احلال المستوطنين بالقوه مكان الفلسطينيين
تثبيت امر واقع وستاتيكو جديد في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك دفع الصحفيين والسكان الى
خارج المدينه اغلاق المحلات التجاريه بقوه
السلاح العربده والاعتداء على اهل البلد
القديمه اذا هدفها بسط السياده ولو بصوره
مفتعله مسيره رقصه الاعلام هذه التي تتكرر
كل عام هي في رمزيتها صراع هويه تريد
اسرائيل من خلالها فرض واقع ضم القدس بعد
احتلالها يقابلها تمسك فلسطيني بالهويه
العربيه للقدس الشرقيه مع رفع للاعلام
الفلسطينيه في مناطق عده من الاراضي
المحتله او المحاصره
اكبر تلك المسيرات كان في قطاع غزه اذ خرج
الالاف في مسيره اعلام فلسطينيه المضاده
ارادوا منها نصره القدس المحتله وتثبيت
وجود الفلسطينيين على ارضهم واظهار تمسكهم
بحقوقهم المشاركه في فعاليه تحت عنوان
فعاليه العالم الفلسطيني ردا على فعاليه
العالم والصهيوني في القدسن على وحده
الشعب الفلسطيني في القدس وغزه والضفه
والشتات وان المعركه معركه السياده في
القدس وعلى القدس مع هذا المحتل لم تنتهي
ولم يسلم شعب فلسطين ابدا بسياده العدو
عليها تعاني القدس كل عام منذ الذكرى
الاولى لاحتلالها قبل سته وخمسين عاما
مسيرات ما يسمى رقصه الاعلام التي كانت
محدوده في البدايه لكنها تحولت خلال
الاعوام القليله الماضيه الى مسيره حاشده
يشارك فيها الالاف من انصار